foreign
Ty here so this is it it's finally here
Google pixel 4A
and this is a really simple one right so
the 3A was Google's budget phone with a
great camera right
double down on that so this 350 bucks is
Google's budget phone with an excellent
camera
and that's really it it doesn't take
long using this phone to figure that out
by the time you see this I've been using
it for almost a week now and really the
formula here is keep it simple
everything here is really clean and
simple I mean just for starters look at
it you know it's the plastic build as
we've all seen and it's all one piece so
you can see there's no seams anywhere on
the sides or the top or the bottom
simple then there's the spec sheet there
is one size one color One spec
simple the whole phone is about the same
size as the iPhone 11 Pro but noticeably
lighter of course thanks to the plastic
and I like the size I think it's a good
one size to have and with that on the
front of the phone you're getting a 5.8
inch 1080p OLED display flat screen 60
hertz and that hole punch cut out for
the selfie camera some people don't like
the hole punch to me honestly really
I've gotten used to it by now and it's
better than a notch it's not the most
incredible display but there's
definitely no big issues with it you're
still looking at well over 400 pixels
per inch and I've noticed a pretty
decent range of brightness and some good
viewing angles the no high refresh rate
at this price isn't a deal breaker but
we'll get to Performance in a second
and then the rest of this Hardware
package is
simple you guessed it you're on the same
page now it's very simple it's all matte
black everything all the way around
giving it uh not a soft touch feel but
more of like this powder coated slight
texture and I like it and of course
there's a signature pixel accented light
green power button and actually these
buttons are super clicky they're pretty
loud too
I think they're the best feeling part of
this phone and there's an honestly
pretty disappointing single mono speaker
at the bottom but in positive news there
is still a headphone jack up top it
lives on with the budget pixel line now
with a lot of phones back a couple years
ago I used to always have this moment
where I would you know bend it twist it
see if I can feel any weird creaking or
anything happening with the phone and I
sort of slow down and stop doing that
because pretty much every phone now is
fine in that department plus Zach does
his durability tests but I got my pixel
4A and I started to do that a little and
there is actually a little bit of
bending to it
I don't know if Zach's gotten his yet
but I'm pretty sure when he does and he
does his test I'm predicting it's going
to snap in half I don't think the
plastic unibody build is the most
durable but on the upside it's not glass
which means it won't shatter so you know
there's ups and downs again with this
whole thing we have to keep the price in
mind it's 350 bucks so I am totally fine
with a matte black unibody plastic build
also if you're clumsy or worried about
dropping your phone you already know
Channel sponsor D Brands got you covered
with their made by Google Certified grip
case it's grippier than the naked phone
and yes it comes in matte black or
literally any other color so you can
check it out at the link below my
favorite part of this Hardware though
and maybe it's the best example of them
truly keeping it simple is the
fingerprint reader still on the back
same place it was on the pixel 3A and
the pixel 2 and the original pixel and
the Nexus 6p and the Nexus 5x look the
point is this is the tried and true
place to put it zero problems with this
fingerprint reader on the back here but
look this is the pixel 4A and we all
know the reason we're here
and it's the cameras
and they're really good spoiler alert
again with photos so there is a single
camera on the back here it kind of
resembles the multi-camera setups with
the rounded rectangle but without
spending the extra money for extra
useless cameras nice and so it's just
one camera and a flash 12 megapixel
sensor at F 1.7 with ois the numbers
aren't too crazy but the photos you get
are exactly what we'd expect right in
the same style as pixel 4. if anything
just a little bit softer but it has that
confident contrasty High dynamic range
look and great color that we're used to
from the pixel which is so awesome at
this price night sight still super clean
I mean these are great photos for a 350
phone and thanks to that I'm totally
fine with it being the single camera on
the back like do I miss the ultra wide a
little bit Yeah I came from a phone with
an ultra wide so a guess a little bit
but at this price I'm not mad do I miss
the depth sensor at all I mean with a
single camera Google's been doing really
good portrait mode photos of animals and
humans and all kinds of objects so I
don't miss the depth sensor at all
do I miss the two megapixel macro camera
no so keeping it simple just works great
here I don't think anyone's going to be
mad this isn't quad cameras and that
also translates to the software
experience as well I remember when I
reviewed the pixel 2 I called it the
smartest smartphone mainly thanks to a
lot of Google features on top of Android
now this budget version carries a couple
less of those googly features but I
still really like the ones it has like
there is no squeeze for assistant they
couldn't build that into the hardware
but you can always swipe up diagonally
from the corner and that gets you to
Google Assistant just as fast there is
no project Soleil or radar sensors up in
the front of this phone but it still has
raised to wake with the accelerometer
and gyroscope and you can turn this on
or off and then it has some of those
pixel exclusive features it has live
caption available everywhere and I still
love call screening and the now playing
which identifies songs in the background
wherever you go and keeps a running list
of them like every time I switch back to
a pixel I love these features and I miss
them on other phones but also like pixel
3A performance on the 4A on this phone
is not that great now at first I thought
it was just me over realizing it because
I just come from these super high-end
120 hertz phones but just having a 60hz
phone shouldn't be a death sentence for
smoothness you should phones were all 60
hertz a couple years ago and smoothness
was fine
so it's a little more than that I feel
like the Snapdragon 730g is probably a
lot more to blame here and I couldn't
stop noticing that it just wasn't very
smooth the phone just doesn't feel fast
I guess is the main point which concerns
me for how long it will last you know
this is one of the bigger sticking
points among a lot of the budget phones
coming out now is when you extrapolate
their value over time you're kind of up
against the gold standard of iPhone se
but this phone has some of the same
issues pixel 3A had which you know
didn't stop people from loving pixel 3A
as it's still a great camera in a phone
for the price but again you should know
what you're getting into but of course
there is one more area where pixel 3A
outperforms the numbers on paper and
that's the battery so this phone has a
3140 milliamp hour battery doesn't seem
like that high of a number because it's
not uh the OnePlus note I just reviewed
had like a 25 bigger battery I wasn't
expecting it to be great but of course I
should know better because it's a 1080p
60hz screen and I was pleasantly
surprised with the battery on the 4A now
again all this quarantine lifestyle
testing so it comes with the asterisk
that all the rest of the phones have had
but if I'm getting five hours of screen
on time comfortably with this phone and
ending the day with 10 to 20 left
consistently I don't think anyone will
have problems with the pixel 4a's
battery so simply put that's about it
for this really simple phone for some
people it's kind of forgettable but for
others it's exactly what we're waiting
for for this new pixel it's doubled down
on everything the 3A had going for it
and lowered the price and so for this
price the the lack of wireless charging
or IP rating or Glass and Metal and
stereo speakers and extra cameras really
isn't a deal breaker in fact it's
expected the simple plastic build is
expected the 60hz screen is fine the
biggest upside is still the camera and
the biggest downside is still the
performance it's really just the only
difference now is the existence of much
more competition in this space with
phones like OnePlus Nord and iPhone SC
now technically this phone undercuts
them both in price which is going to
matter to a lot of people 350 bucks is
an insane price for the amount of phone
you're getting here and all these
features but each each one of these
phones is going to have its own distinct
advantages iPhone and Nord are going to
be better performers iPhone's going to
take better video but you get more
Google features here better Stills
camera so it's what you want I just
really love that it feels like Google's
getting a little more competitive with
this pixel phone getting that lower
price to undercut the competitors to
give you a reason to buy it it's great I
just hope this translates into them
making a true high-end pixel 5 flagship
now I don't know if that's smart to get
my hopes up for that considering their
track record is not very good for
flagships but that's what I'm hoping
this competitiveness translates into but
we'll see if that happens either way
that's been it pixel 4A
pretty simple
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace